[Music]
on this friday night the military's
fight against the flood waters in bc
that dike is has been weakened to what
degree we do not know that
reinforcements rush to rescue the
water-ravaged region as crews face tough
decisions over which homes to save
it's official canadian kids will soon
get a covid shot in the arm what parents
need to know as ottawa relaxes the rules
for some travelers and moves to
recognize more vaccine
the verdict is in
members of the jury are these your
unanimous verdicts the celebration and
indignation at the kyle rittenhouse
trial
plus the big move to small towns this is
one of the most significant changes in
migrant flows since the industrial
revolution what's driving canadians to
the countryside
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with breaking news tonight
the bc government has just unveiled new
measures to safeguard the gasoline
supply in areas hit by this week's
catastrophic flooding keith baldry is in
victoria for us tonight so keith the
province has just issued two orders
under the emergency program act what do
they mean for people in that province
yeah bc public safety minister mike
farnworth imposing two emergency orders
one installs travel restrictions on two
of the main highways that link metro
vancouver to the rest of the province
limited to only essential travel and
emergency travel that was expected what
i think caught a lot of people off guard
was a form of gas rationing now
introduced in southwest bc motorists at
the pump will be limited to just 30
liters of gasoline per visit to the pump
minister farmer is saying this is all
about protecting the gasoline supply for
emergency vehicles and asking british
columbians to be kind to each other
during a very trying time
i urge british columbians to be kind and
patient at the gas stations everyone is
doing their absolute best to make sure
those who need gas get it
right now we all need to do our part to
make sure that emergency and essential
vehicles can do their jobs
and keith the troun's mountain trans
mountain pipeline carries most of the
gasoline into southwestern bc so what's
its status tonight
yeah it's been down for a few days now
jeff because of the flooding the
pipeline passes through where areas are
in deep underwater the good news is
though the government announced today
trans mountain has informed them that
they hope the pipeline is up and
operating by the end of next week which
is why the gas ratio is likely only in
place for about 10 or 11 days
keith baldry with that breaking news in
victoria for us tonight thanks keith the
situation in british columbia remains
critical tonight especially in
abbotsford the city about an hour's
drive southeast of vancouver take a look
at these new pictures revealing the
scale of the damage caused by the
flooding now this is where the sumas
river dike fell apart crews are now
working to fill that gap which is
roughly a hundred meters wide the
military is rushing in to help 64
members are now there on the ground and
more are on the way from ontario and
quebec teams are scrambling to contain
the damage in a race against time with
more rain in the forecast for the latest
on that city's fight against the flood
waters let's go to global's jordan
armstrong who is in abbotsford where
officials have just provided an update
jordan
they have jeff and here's the latest
tonight there's been a significant
change in strategy a plan to build a two
and a half kilometer long levee on the
trans-canada highway has been shelved it
is not going to happen instead of a
levee this is now the immediate focus
closing that 100 meter long break in
abbotsford's major dike the break is
allowing water to flow south over the
highway and into the sumas valley where
there are hundreds of properties now
just yesterday the city had favored the
much larger levee as a way to block the
water and ultimately repair the dike but
that plan would have taken more time and
it would have led to the short-term
sacrifice of 22 properties in the area
between the proposed levy and the broken
dike here's abbotsford mayor henry braun
with what has changed
because the conditions on the ground
have changed the water has
equalized on both sides so we don't have
water pouring into the
into the bowl
and so when we learned this new
information we had some options that we
didn't have before
before the pivot and strategy was
announced today there was a lot of
confusion amongst residents some didn't
know if their property would be spared
or sacrificed for a levy
very unclear we don't know what's going
on
we're just
acting like it's still going to be there
though so we're still gutting it out and
stuff
and just hoping it'll be there but we
don't know if what the deal is
now more than one official has used the
phrase race against time and that is
because of the weather today has been
dry the weekend looks mostly dry the
mayor is confident they can fix the
dike at least temporarily by early next
week when more rain is in the forecast
jeff
jordan armstrong reporting from
abbotsford bc tonight thanks jordan
and it has been a year of
record-breaking weather events in b.c
coming up later we'll look at the
connection to climate change and what
can be done to avert future disasters
to the pandemic now and it's the news
canadian parents have been waiting to
hear children aged 5 to 11 are now
officially eligible for pfizer
biontech's kids vaccine health canada
issued approval today after its review
found the vaccine to be safe and
effective jamie morocco has more on what
parents need to know including how and
when the rollout will begin
many parents are breathing a sigh of
relief their kids under 12 will finally
be able to get their coveted shots after
the first dose i'll be able to relax
as early as next week pfizer says vials
of its pediatric formula will start to
arrive at vaccine sites across the
country but exact timelines will differ
from province to province it is expected
all 2.9 million doses will be delivered
by next friday that's enough doses to
offer a first shot to all eligible
children in this country we are working
closely with pfizer to firm up the exact
schedule for delivery of the second
doses health canada says first and
second doses can be given as early as
three weeks apart while the national
advisory committee on immunization
recommends waiting at least eight weeks
doctors agree weighting has its benefits
and actually have a lower risk of
something like myocarditis
inflammation around the heart a rare
side effect not seen in young kids
during pfizer's latest trial one of the
challenges ahead getting hesitant
parents on board kelly turpin a montreal
mom with 3 under 10 among them i really
feel like my instinct is saying no you
have healthy kids you're always outdoor
there's no health issue so far more than
two million american kids have received
the comedy vaccine by and large with
only mild side effects a sore arm or a
low grade fever today no new safety
issues have emerged from the use of
community and children a combination
experts say is our best shot at
returning to normal jamie morocco global
news toronto
and for parents wondering exactly when
vaccinations will begin as jamie
mentioned the rollout plans will vary by
province in british columbia officials
expect children's doses to start the
week of november 29th saskatchewan has
said it will be ready to roll out shots
as soon as they're delivered in ontario
local public health units will be
setting up clinics in schools while in
quebec officials say the goal is to get
first doses to every eligible child by
christmas
and starting november the 30th canadians
no longer need those pricey pcr tests to
return home from quick trips to the
united states as long as they're fully
vaccinated and away for less than 72
hours the government is also expanding
the list of accepted covit 19 vaccines
from travelers david aiken reports on
the new rules
just in time for canadians who want to
zip across the border for some christmas
shopping the federal government is
changing the rules for travelers coming
back to canada
returning travelers will not need a test
if they are a fully vaccinated canadian
and have been out of the country for
less than 72 hours unvaccinated kids
with parents qualify for this exemption
which goes into effect november 30th but
all foreign nationals including
americans as well as vaccinated
canadians coming back from a longer trip
will still need a molecular test the
most common of which is a pcr test
before arriving at the border we are
taking a cautious phased approach
to lifting layers of border measures
we are definitely not out of the woods
the panoramic is very much alive over
the world
canada is also adding three vaccines to
the list of those that it recognizes for
the purposes of travel ceno farm sinovac
and kovaxin i strongly urge all
travelers canadian and foreign nationals
to verify all entry requirements before
they travel to ensure they meet all
mandatory requirements
finally travelers who are currently
exempt from entry requirements will need
to get vaccinated this includes
professional athletes and essential
service providers including truck
drivers they'll all need to be fully
vaccinated by january the 15th or face
mandatory quarantine and testing david
aiken global news ottawa
the united states is now offering
booster shots for covid 19 vaccines to
all adult americans the head of the
centers for disease control and
prevention signed off on unanimous
recommendations from a group of advisors
the decision means anyone 18 and older
is now eligible to get pfizer or moderna
as a booster though it must be at least
six months since their second dosed the
boosters are expected to begin in the
coming days
to europe now and an extraordinary move
to get more people vaccinated austria is
set to become the first country in the
eu to make covid19 vaccines mandatory
starting in february austrians who
refuse to be vaccinated could face fines
or even prison time people who can't get
the shot for medical reasons will be
exempt 66 percent of austrians are fully
vaccinated that's among the lowest rates
in western europe with cases surging the
entire country is set to enter another
full lockdown on monday
germany meanwhile is also looking at
another lockdown covid cases there hit a
record high this week and the country's
head of disease control declared a
nationwide state of emergency officials
say hospitals are overstretched and
regular medical care can no longer be
guaranteed 67 percent of germans are
fully vaccinated
to the u.s now and a bombshell verdict
in a case that has divided the country a
jury has found kyle rittenhouse not
guilty on all charges rittenhouse was 17
when he showed up armed to a racial
justice protest last year in wisconsin
he shot three men killing two of them
the teen argued it was self-defense
jackson proskow has more on the ruling
and reaction
the jury find the defendant kyle h
not guilty as the jurors delivered their
verdict on each of the five counts not
guilty kyle rittenhouse was overcome
with emotion not guilty
collapsing in the courtroom as the final
not guilty was read aloud
[Applause]
outside jubilation from supporters of
the teen it validates that we have a
second amendment right to defend
ourselves and protect us
and anger from the families of the
victims and supporters of jacob blake
blake was shot by kenosha police
touching off the racial justice protests
where rittenhouse shot three men killing
two
these jurors saw a different america
than we see every day
the lengthy trial was defined by
rittenhouse's own emotional testimony
and by a judge who repeatedly sparred
with the prosecution that's basic law
it's been basic law in this country for
40 years 50 years
yet it all came down to one central
question was written house acting as a
vigilante or in self-defense you cannot
claim self-defense against a danger you
create the prosecution portrayed written
house as a wannabe soldier who went
looking for trouble and fame when he
showed up armed to the protests no
serious credible medic wears an ar-15
slung around their body written house's
lawyers argued the shootings were an act
of self-preservation
saying the then 17-year-old traveled to
the city from his home in illinois to
protect property from rioters when he
was ambushed every person
who was shot
was attacking kyle ultimately
prosecutors were unable to convince the
jury that rittenhouse was not acting in
self-defense the jury system works and
you have to abide by it once facing life
in prison the 18 year old is now a free
man though he still could face civil
suits
in a country polarized by issues of race
politics and gun violence rittenhouse
will have to choose whether to fade
quietly into private life or embrace his
newfound infamy
jackson prosko global news washington
in a historic first u.s vice president
kamala harris became acting president
today for about 85 minutes as joe biden
underwent a routine colonoscopy the
brief transfer of power made history
harris becoming the first woman to
temporarily assume presidential powers
she held the authority while biden was
under anesthesia biden is the oldest
person to serve as u.s president he in
fact turns 79 tomorrow
after massive protests india's prime
minister repeals his farming reforms
coming up the suspicions about an
ulterior motive
those celebrations erupted in surrey bc
last night over india's surprise
decision to repeal controversial
agriculture laws crowds of people took
to the streets after prime minister
narendra modi buckled under public
pressure
for more than a year tens of thousands
of farmers have been fighting three laws
they say those rules threatened to
destroy their livelihoods as crystal
gomencing reports modi's move may have
more to do with protecting his party's
political future
around india farmers swarmed the streets
in victory
still they say the government hasn't
seen the last of them just yet
when it's completed in writing only then
will we go
this should have been done earlier
about 60
of india's workforce is employed in the
agricultural sector in 2020 when
narendra modi's government made changes
to the legislation claiming to modernize
it farmers rebelled saying the
government was cutting their profits
demonstrators blocked roads and
government offices and there was
violence multiple farm unions which
helped to organize the rallies over the
past year say 170 farmers were killed
but that number has not been
independently verified
support rallies were held in several
countries
including canada
i have come to tell you the whole
country that we have decided to withdraw
repeal all three agricultural laws
modi's u-turn comes ahead of elections
next year in several key states
including uttar pradesh it's the most
populous state and its economy relies on
agriculture advocates say the move was
about the bjp maintaining power not to
sound cynical but
uh it is good and it's a reprieve in the
short term that these farm laws have
been repealed
but it wasn't because the government
suddenly you know is is
hearing the needs of the common people
it really was a politically motivated
decision and political fates now lie in
the hands of the same farmers labeled as
anti-nationals terrorists and goons for
taking to the streets to protect their
livelihoods
crystal commansing global news london
from fires to floods still ahead bc's
extreme weather and the connection to
climate change
you're watching global national
[Music]
welcome back 2021 has been a roller
coaster of weather extremes in british
columbia once in a hundred year events
are happening much more frequently and
communities in bc's unique and variable
climate are facing calls to do more to
plan and prepare eric sorenson reports
was it just a coincidence that southern
bc baked and burned under a deadly heat
dome last summer that killed nearly 600
people then was inundated with rain and
floods less than five months later both
were meteorological extremes that
experts not only link to climate change
and expect to see more often but are
events that can generate their own chain
reaction the summer heat created
conditions to make the rainfall impact
worse everything is connected there's no
doubt about that the heat of last summer
smothered southern british columbia in
addition to trees burning vegetation was
widely reduced by the lack of moisture
the soil dried became less capable of
absorption then came fall rains and
early autumn snow that saturated the
ground
days ago an intense atmospheric river
dumped enormous amounts of water quickly
the now oversaturated ground gave way in
places creating landslides especially in
steep areas
absolutely
the events
in the summer play a role in our winter
even a heat event can have unintended
results what is often viewed as an
idyllic setting bc's unique terrain and
ecosystem can contribute to different
weather extremes you have mountains on
one side flat areas you know in the
middle and then you have ocean and
coastal impacts are all contributing to
the severity of severity of these events
it's heartbreaking it's livelihoods the
disaster and the prospect of more
climate extremes makes for an uncertain
future we had our hopes for next year
but now it's all flooded so we don't
know about next year either british
columbia has developed a climate
preparedness strategy to build more
resilience from forest management to
strengthening homes but decades of
construction from the past is not ready
for the climate of the future
enormous investments will have to be
made as well as decisions about where to
invest and where to live we need to look
at all of our existing infrastructure
there are some hard conversations to be
had around where people might be in
places that are
that are really in harm's way and
they're going to be hard to protect in
the future
experts believe british colombians and
all canadians must do more to plan for
the climate extremes that are coming and
not just respond when catastrophe
strikes
eric sorenson global news
next rural rush canadian urbanites are
flocking to small towns and causing big
problems
a seismic housing shift is happening
across canada with the pandemic and an
affordability crisis millennials are
leaving big cities to settle in small
towns reversing a decades-old trend but
the change is bringing challenges krista
hesse reports from markdale ontario
during ontario's first lockdown graham
demarsh and ashley patrick left their
tiny condo in toronto behind and bought
a home in markdale
we are walking country song we came we
got the dog we bought the pickup truck
it's really amazing
markdale a town of just 1200 people has
exploded since the pandemic began
with many offices remaining closed young
professionals like ashley and graham are
no longer tied to their deaths or their
cities
we really were big city people and it
was it's a hard change but it's one that
we look back on and we're we're very
happy we made it
rural destinations are no longer this
backwater
outdated outmoded
place to live anymore
young people were already starting to
move to rural canada before 2020 but
experts we spoke with say the pandemic
accelerated the trend newcomers to
markdale are opening new businesses and
hundreds of homes are being built to
keep up with demand these towns are
alive again
that's the good news the bad news is
that
it also with this rapid price
appreciation it pushes locals out of the
housing market potentially
and that's what's happened in markdale
house prices have nearly doubled
ironically the affordability crisis that
people from the city are trying to
escape has followed them into the
country
it's one of the unexpected consequences
of the pandemic but many locals here are
hopeful that in the end it will enrich
this small town
christa hessie global news markdale
ontario and to see more of that
remarkable transformation and the new
challenges for small town canada you can
watch krista's full documentary on the
new reality that's tomorrow at seven
o'clock right here on global
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm jeff semple we leave
you tonight with a historic look at the
night sky those who stayed up late or
woke up early this morning got to feast
their eyes on this spectacular partial
lunar eclipse it peaked for three hours
the longest in centuries thanks for
watching robin gill will be at the
anchor desk with you tomorrow and i'll
see you here again on sunday have a
great night
[Music]